hey buddy you that fish boy from the TV
it's this man you get unite our worlds
one day the lamb
about you the world needs something more
a hero
[Music]
rated pg-13 see the expended video on
YouTube now my father was a lighthouse
keeper
my mother was queen but life has a way
of bringing people together could unite
our boys one day
check it out author is talking to the
fish
they made me what I am
listen to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I'm looking
do your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all
that was the worst pep talk ever I want
to strap in
my brother has come for the service
chatters me for the throne I got an
ass-whooping
I'm no leader
because I have no choice
you can't save my home and the people
that I love
you think you're unworthy to lead
because you're two different worlds that
is exactly why you are worthy
oh it's awesome
the war is coming to the surface
bringing the wrath of the seven seas
with me
what are you doing have a parachute
right hoods
[Music]